alright ladies and gentlemen Chris
waters here from the gamespot stage at
Comic Con 2014 joining me now is al hope
from Creative Assembly your talk about
alien isolation al glad to have you here
man it's great to be i feels like just
recently you and i were sitting down
talking about alien isolation back at e3
but since then you guys have made some
big announcements about the cast of the
original movie yeah so quite amazingly
it was kind of a dream come true we've
much to bring together a bunch of the
original cast to sort of reprise their
roles as the original Nostromo crew and
we're releasing some bonus content in
which you can as a player take on one of
those crew members and try and survive
against our signature alien a signature
alien that xenomorph so now the game
alien isolation takes place after the
events of alien it's sort of
investigating to try to figure out what
went down during the movie timeline so
the alien isolation itself takes place
15 years off them the strongest yes
missing and you play Amanda Ripley so
Ellen if his daughter she's trying to
find answers as to mother's
disappearance and then when weyland
yutani discovered that they believe
someone has found the black box flight
recorder Minister omo she volunteers be
she's got to go in ya gotta go and find
it so connected then too we're just
catching a glimpse there of the cast
members connected then to to them and
sort of how where that piece of content
fits into the to the game yeah so I mean
the the new crew expendable content is
very much bonus content it's not it's
kind of it kind of takes you back to
that original 15 years earlier when the
crew are trying to survive against the
alien on the stroma inside that pressure
cooker you know there's no escape we
just have to try and deal with that so
is it is kind of just kind of separate
to our main story but it's obviously
it's kind of connected through the
connection of mother and daughter sure
now that one of the things that you guys
have been so diligent about and I think
has lent a lot of its create a lot of
the appeal for alien isolation is how
much you
guys are channeling that the aesthetic
of the movie and sci-fi in that time and
you know the green CRT monitors and just
the the way you're trying to make it
look like the movie look so you know
making us you know have getting
Sigourney Weaver in to talk about the
game is one thing but you're not are you
not mo capping her and capturing her
face to make her look like Ellen Ripley
when the original game came out well as
you one of the interesting thing was
when we started with doing this amazing
production archive from 20th Century Fox
I'm one of the great things was all
these continuity photos of the cast on
set back in 1979 and sorry there's
amazing front and side shots really so
that was like there's our treasure trove
from which we could build 3d models from
those those faces from 35 years ago so
is it amazing kind of resource so weak
so you know when we were able to
recreate these these likenesses we're
kind of able to take them back in time
and how cool to have that those are
still images as opposed to you guys
trying to like pause the movie and sign
a frame that like I was every plan a is
just like a look at what can we get out
of the film mm-hmm so did you when did
you get to talk to to the to the actors
themselves and sort of talk about what
the game and what you guys are trying to
do and sort of get their reaction
absolutely i mean we took them through
you know the premise of the game what
we're trying to do the approach we're
taking you know going back to that
original kind of you know Ridley Scott
haunted house in space and you know it
you know alien isolation being much more
survival you know game rather than
trying to be kind of game about killing
yeah i think you know whence they saw
these kind of attention to detail and
the fact that we were taking taking the
player back to that original roots of
the series that you know i think they've
been really exciting oh yeah and you
know we worked really closely with them
on their likeness and on the voice
recording which anyways just an
incredible experience to sit and listen
to those cast members take on those
rolls again and start you know acting
out being on the stroma once once more
very cool did they did they have moments
they have flashbacks like I remember
that piece of the set or all those walls
they were no you touch them and they
feel really weird but they look cool
so I mean actually we were we were
taught we actually met up with Sigourney
Weaver early on this week and I was able
to show the latest version of the code
and it was great be able to walk through
the Nostromo corridor and for husband
gay night you know I walked through
there I know I've actually been on set
there you know I think there's a really
you know you were saying a real kind of
high fidelity reproduction of that
original set Wow I mean you mentioned it
before but total dream come true right
for this is such a passion project for
you guys you love it so much absolutely
i mean you know it to be in a position
to make this game in the first place
never really deeply love that first film
and he's got to make this game you know
was it kind of a dream come true but
then you know when I think when you
start project like this you have all
these ideas you know and and we were
thinking where we created the original
alien how about what if what if I
original crew came came face to face
with it again you know and you know it
was great to be able to be in a position
to show the original cast hey this is
what we're doing it for them to get
really really excited and get behind the
project very cool and so that's but to
clarify again that original cast stuff
is part of a it's currently a pre-order
bonus yeah that's correct um and so
that's and that's something people can
order now because the games coming out
in just a few months yeah outside the
7th October seventh and you guys are
also giving people on the show floor
here at comic-con a taste of the action
yeah but this is not I mean this isn't a
game to play on a crowded show floor no
so it's a very cool so that we've got
we've built this enormous alien egg is
where you can go inside one at a time
and experience the
the kind of time-based challenge which
is just a really stripped-down
experience it's just you an alien motion
tracker and a flamethrower and sitting
how long you can survive it's just been
absolutely fantastic it's very
intentional you know it's very loud
you're isolated and it's just you and
the screen and it's been fantastic
watching because we have a camera inside
the egg and so the audience outside can
watch your reaction and really here kind
of oohs and ahhs is as people attempt to
survive and you know big kind of big
cheers when people kind of when they get
close to making it so it's you know
somebody really really fantastic
experience do you record the the like
screams also and the god coming out of
there we should do them a bit better
yeah very cool so alien isolation coming
out october 7th on which consoles xbox
one xbox 360 playstation 4 playstation 3
and pc and pc and you guys must be
pretty pretty much closing in on
finishing this thing up by now right
yeah the amazing team bacca bacca the
studio just just sort of fine-tuning
everything and just polishing and you
know it seems like this where where we
get to put the game in front of people
and put actually put it in their hands
and get them to play it and we need to
get their feedback and we can kind of
take that back to the studio for that
sort of last minute finds Union very
cool we actually have a question coming
in here over Twitter wondering sort of
back to asking about you know you guys
talking about using that source material
right did you use blueprints from the
movie to recreate the Nostromo did you
sort of also take liberties you know
sort of with the foot floor plan yeah so
yes is this is this Joe answer with you
know with that was one of the other
great archive of source material was was
the actual set design blueprint so we're
able to map out the Nostromo as it was
designed and built of course that was a
film set and we wanted to make sure it
was a great game experience and so we've
made some quite subtle changes just just
to make sure it's a great you know
player experience but I think he knew
on the whole it is more or less a
one-for-one reproduce and you'll be able
to have those moments you know if you
watch the movie a few times like
Sigourney head of oh I recognize this
hole yeah oh yeah whether it's on the
bridge or in down in engineering you
know it's for highly recognizable very
cool al well you guys also you haven't
some more showings here at San Diego
comic-con you guys have another
presentation going on yes over a nerd HQ
at Petco Park we have another slice of
the game and that's actually taken from
the main game and that's a lot longer
experience it's about a 20 minute demo
and again that just takes you to the
drop chute in the middle of the game
it's kind of quite a challenging
experience but I think a lot people get
a huge amount out of it again it's you
in the alien and quite simply a motion
tracker but it's a slightly extended
experience so no you know everyone
should check it out yeah are you finding
that people coming out of it or having
the experience you're hoping them to
have of it of that demo being a good
microcosm of sort of what the game is
about yeah just watching people play is
massively rewarding and really exciting
and I've seen people come out with
massive smiles on their faces even
though they've been killed quite a few
times I think I'm an adrenaline rush and
you can see them having this physical
reaction you know as it gets scared
playing it is fantastic well I'll so
happy to talk to you again about alien
isolation it's always a pleasure very
cool to hear about the new the pre-order
stuff with the original cast come on
enjoy the rest of your show here and
folks that's alien isolation coming out
October seventh with the preorder bonus
with the original cast voice acted and
mapped into the game very cool